ever since the russians pulled out a few
weeks ago detective victoria nemerova
and her team have been exhuming bodies
at least 10 daily a task she never
thought she would be doing when she
first joined the police this time her
team is unearthing the body of a person
buried in the backyard of a house
they carefully dig
carving around the body
trying to figure out how it's positioned
these are the feet so the head is over
there she says
a first assessment reveals it's a man
who appears to be in his sixties
it's only when they flip the body over
that she finds a clue into the cause of
death
he's got a wound at the back of the head
most likely it's from a bullet because
he had blood coming out of the mouth
the body is decomposing and the skin is
stuck to the clothes
so in order not to damage it more we
will take him away and then the forensic
expert will investigate further we found
his phone we will charge it and
hopefully find out more about him
the full scope of what happened when the
russian soldiers left the towns north of
cave is still not clear but the trail of
destruction left behind is evident
civilians have been telling about how
they were directly targeted as they were
trying to flee their bullet holes all
over this windshield but this car was
hit by some large caliber ammunition
from the side here and you can see still
the remains of what appears to be a
white flag marking the fact that they
were civilians in this vehicle and then
here on this side of the car you see the
point of exit
of whatever ripped through the car and
inside it's mayhem you still actually
have blood stains everywhere and in the
middle of all that a passport
it belongs to a young man who was born
in september 1990.
children who who killed
this is the number and our children but
again we don't it's another example of
alleged war crimes among the thousands
of cases that investigators have been
documenting says ukraine's prosecutor
general
she has dispatched teams around the
country to gather evidence
here in burujanka they're set up in a
classroom and it's full of people
telling their stories
again killing civilians some of them
were after tortured tortured civilians
we
now
started to prosecute sexual crimes
raping we see it unfortunately we see
then they took a property of civilians
or we see again that they bombed again
and again they bombed civilian
infrastructure hospitals kind of harder
and schools more than 1 000 educational
institutions destroyed in ukraine what
is this of course it's military it is
war crime
nearby bucha the morgue is overwhelmed
refrigerated trucks are also overflowing
with bodies olga finally found her
husband after coming here for several
days he was killed while she was away in
poland
the neighbors called and said me he was
shot on march 20th he was going to the
garage to get some food two russian
soldiers saw him ran after him and shot
him twice the russians didn't allow the
body to be picked up for three days
[Music]
russia denies committing any atrocities
suggesting they've been staged but the
u.n human rights office says there is
growing evidence of war crimes committed
by russian soldiers
and fears many more could emerge as the
fighting continues in the east and south
of the country
al-jazeera north of keefe